Ironman is the greatest of all the
heroes of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so why did his solo films stop at three
in a recent Vanity Fair interview
Avengers in game screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
shed some light on why the armored
Avenger never got a fourth solo outing
simply put the scribes related that
Marvel Studios brass felt that another
flick centered on The Adventures of the
MCU s most popular character would have
been a little bit too safe McFeely made
the point that Marvel has never been
particularly interested in doing exactly
what's expected of it for evidence he
pointed to its decision to take a chance
on one property in particular James
Gunn's guardians of the galaxy
rather than cranking out sequels for its
most popular Avengers one after another
some over a flame to this children
delicious McFeely explained whether you
like all of the 24 movies or not the
capital that Marvel built up allowed
them to do things like make a movie
starring a raccoon and a tree right you
would have already had Iron Man for if
it was any other studio but they decided
no we're going to take chances on all
these other things to illustrate further
how Marvel's affinity for risk-taking
has paid off the scribe suggested that
we should look no further than endgame
the highest-grossing film of all time
and one that definitively removed Iron
Man and Captain America the MC use most
recognizable players from its
increasingly crowded bored McFeely
admitted quote to put a flag in the
ground and say we're going to end
something and take characters off the
table is I think kind of daring but
selfishly it was really great for us
Marcus then chimed in with the final
word not only on why Iron Man 4 never
happened and never will but why Tony
Stark had to meet his end at the
conclusion of endgame he said a story
needs an ending or it loses meaning the
end is what cements the thing to
actually sew it together and bring it to
a crescendo and yet take people off the
board finish their arts if Tony made it
out the other side and Iron Man 4 was
waiting there you'd be like one too many
nest hero Gaiden 3 journeys to end it
just serves to illustrate the extent to
which Marvel has its finger on the pulse
of its audience it knows them well
enough to not only know what they want
but what they might not have even
known they wanted it's true having stark
defeat Thanos only to pay a minimal
price would have cheapened his action to
then bring him back for Ironman for
would have been a transparent cash grab
of the sort that the studio has thus far
steered way clear of it's not even that
Marvel is opposed to fort walls for
individual Avengers Thor after all will
be getting a fourth solo flick with the
upcoming Thor love and thunder but he is
a character who happens to be smack dab
in the midst of a huge profound shift in
his priorities his transformation from
often stoic sometimes unintentionally
funny god of thunder - hilarious
clinically depressed still badass as
guardian of the galaxy didn't begin in
earnest until 2017 s thor ragnarok and
the earth-shattering events of Avengers
infinity war and in game left him with a
lot of unanswered questions about who he
really is and also with a lot of room
for growth stark on the other hand
underwent a complete and convincing
character arc between inaugural MCU
effort Ironman and ingame the so-called
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist didn't even begin to
learn the meaning of teamwork and
sacrifice until 2012's The Avengers and
the events of Iron Man 3 and Captain
America Civil War forced him to confront
his own shortcomings in a way that he
had never before done if infinity war
finally made him come to terms with the
possibility heck the cold reality of
abject failure then endgame saw him
learned that even such failure doesn't
give one license to simply give up and
that some things like the love of
friends and family are worth giving
everything for it was as complete and
moving an arc as any superhero could
have ever hoped for
of course this probably doesn't mean
that Marvel fans will never see Iron Man
again signs are pointing to at least a
cameo in the upcoming solo vehicle Black
Widow which takes place between the
events of Civil War and infinity war and
there are conflicting reports as to
whether Downey will reprise the role in
the Disney Plus animated series what if
but as far as Starks actual complete
story in the MCU goes we're of the
opinion that it couldn't have been
executed any better and that Markus and
McFeely are absolutely correct Iron Man
4 would have been one too many however
we can't help but hope that Marvel finds
a way to let Taika Waititi keep on
making four movies forever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one